impeachment is the big story one of the
people caught up in the controversy of
course is former national security
adviser John Bolton yeah well guess what
it turns out last week Bolton signed a
major book deal this is real news he
signed a book deal I thought I'd be
John Bolton's first book it turns out
John Bolton is a very prolific writer
he's written on many different subjects
for example there's his hardware how-to
classic Bolton with Bolton what's a good
one there's his book about birds losing
their feathers called molten with Bolton
there's his popular fitness book boken
with Bolton come on I'm sorry I just
have to say that those joke pictures are
awful yeah yeah they're really I mean
the audience was kind of going for it
but they're really not that yeah that I
mean the jokes are bad the graphic is
terrible Billy put the last one yeah
yeah I see what it is the proportions
are way off show that the proportions
are just way way off on that it's just
not good who's doing these for us well I
think it's obviously got to be Carl he's
the new guy in graphics Oh Carl I
haven't met him yet could we get Carl
out here to talk to him hey did you want
to see me Conan yet Carl did you you did
the graphics on the John Bolton book
yeah yeah I did is there something wrong
with them
everything's fine you nailed it okay
great great glad to hear it all right
see you later okay take it easy
yeah all right we're going to
[Applause]